[laughter]
- NO DOUBT.
NO DOUBT. DEFINITELY.
WHAT UP, DOGS?
YEAH, MAN.
WHAT'S UP?
I'M ADAM DEMAMP.
I JUST TRANSFERRED
FROM THE OTHER SCHOOL
THAT'S PRETTY FAR AWAY
FROM HERE.
UM...
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME.
I TRAIN WITH KETTLE BELLS
AND MY FAVORITE MOVIES
ARE NOTORIOUS AND BLOW,
SO I'M, LIKE, A--
JUST REAL.
I'M SO--A REAL DUDE
LIKE YOU GUYS.
- HEY, WHAT'S UP,
DUDES, BABE?
- WHOA.
YOU'RE QUAID FRANKLIN.
YOU'RE SO GOOD
AT FOOTBALL, DUDE.
I READ THIS WHOLE PAPER
ABOUT YOU.
14 TOUCHDOWNS,
2,238 YARDS.
HE'S GOING TO NEBRASKA
NEXT YEAR.
IT'S--YOU'RE THE MAN, DUDE.
- YEAH, WHO ARE YOU?
- [laughs]
I'M--I'M ADAM DEMAMP.
I JUST INTRODUCED MYSELF,
BUT...
THEY USED TO CALL ME
MEAT MOUNTAIN IN HIGH SCHOOL.
- YO, DUDES.
THERE'S THIS NERD IN
THE BATHROOM THAT'S TRYING TO,
LIKE--I DON'T KNOW--
[bleep] DUDES OR SOMETHING.
- THAT'S ONE THING
THAT I HATE--NERDS!
RIGHT?
UGH!
LET'S GO POUND THIS NERD!
QUAID, LET'S GO POUND
THIS NERD--
ME AND YOU, BRO!
BASH BROS!
LET'S GO, QUAID AND ADAM!
[chanting]
LET'S GO, WOLVES.
LET'S GO!
- HEY, MAN,
HOW COME YOU'RE HERE?
ME?
I WAS STEALING, MAN.
GOT CAUGHT UP STEALING STATUES.
YOU EVER STEAL STATUES, MAN?
YOU EVER STEAL,
LIKE, A, UH--
A DRAGON STATUE?
- EXCUSE ME.
- HUH?
- PLEASE BE QUIET.
THANK YOU.
- MAN, I DIDN'T EVEN
DO ANYTHING.
DANG!
OKAY?
- THAT'S IT.
YOU KNOW, SHAWN-DERS--
- WHAT?
- THAT'S IT.
WE'RE GOING TO THE OFFICE.
- OKAY.
- GIVE ME YOUR I.D.
LET'S SEE IT.
- YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT A STOLEN STATUE?
- WE'RE GOING TO THE OFFICE.
- MAN, STOP. GET OFF ME, DUDE!
- HOW ABOUT WE GIVE
YOUR PARENTS A CALL?
- WHAT? OKAY, WAIT, WAIT.
STOP, STOP, STOP, STOP.
I'M NOT SHAWN-DERS, OKAY?
- [chanting]
LET'S GO, WOLVES!
LET'S GO--
OH!
WRONG GUY.
THAT'S--
WE SHOULD GO CHECK
ANOTHER BATHROOM.
- NO, NO, NO.
THAT'S HIM.
AND IT'S TIME
TO WHUP HIS ASS.
- NO!
OR HEAR ME OUT.
WE COULD REALLY PUNISH
THIS PERV...
AAAAND...
GIVE HIM A SWIRLY.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YEAH!
- I JUST WASHED MY HAIR.
COME ON.
HOLD ON.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO!